welcome to this video this is as pendous
with a white playing against me what to
do yeah let's do something different
here going further a woodbane only the
clothes benoni no should be seven there
is probably difference between the two
moves and i'm not totally aware of can i
play recently this against the Sun
American player aiza Hoffman and he also
has released a book on that I didn't
really get much there he somehow managed
to get him beehive and it didn't feel
that great for me let's see him not sure
that was exactly how he played it but he
managed to get in b5 and it wasn't great
so let's see okay I get in before you as
well hmm that doesn't look so bad what
about Knight b6 can I actually pressure
him there a little bit hmm if he takes
it I can also i can also just capture
there why not get his it's night back
there and now this looks kind of weakish
this pond and the push of a six-night be
six maybe hmm interesting
my position is not bad yeah I think
let's see however yeah and I cannot
really increase the pressure here I
wondered maybe I can do that i am queen
d 7 for Queen 84 Knight c3 I'm going to
take is a little bit a little bit
uncoordinated so Queen a fire that was
the idea in the first place oh if you
moves the Queen now i can probably take
c form but maybe hmm and i can takes it
home was thinking maybe you can ya hear
but I can take it right look a one Queen
B 5 there's nothing wrong with that in
particular at least I don't see it let's
think about it for just a moment can
also take with the bishop and then
Quinby 594 look a one Queen B 5 rook
takes a 6 is this may be an idea are 92
okay seven I can take me to jail look
strange I can also check with the bishop
there's really nothing wrong with that
it's got look a five maybe
ok let's take with that I also didn't
see why this shouldn't work
after rugae 692 that's also eat to
hanging so I don't see a problem with
that here not only to Hanks if you
trades I'm taking on c4 with the tempo
and then look aah to trade rooks nopee
moved this ok so i can take it to hear
right take e to retake c7 on what I'm
taking beaten hmm huh
Casey to take c7 I one that says
something good there Queen Queen B to
root a six and yeah that's not so bright
you can also just cover that let's cover
it know how I'm doing that getting out
of Bishop everyone and I can go back to
be 7 next it's a temple against the
bishop there ok so I'm just going back I
just got rugby one habit that's no big
deal
oops White Rose I yes that accelerated
things enormously yeah but I think it
was just a pawn yeah that set up that he
chose this is White's mean main line
basically against this opening um I have
to admit that I play that myself but um
this this plan here with quickly going
for b5 had irritated me against this
this some guy this is a Hoffman and I
got it in here as well and it really is
nice now I mean be three maybe but well
definitely i can play something like
this yeah then maybe like Quinn side is
closed and i can i'm relatively flexible
on the kingside white has f4 as an idea
of course but currently his pieces are
not very well coordinated and i might
get in something that allows me to play
a fire myself and the way it went i was
in really nice shape here takes takes
takes oh so Bishop a six is even better
okay yeah that is in fact far better
right I mean what is this move now here
you just lose this the porn i think yeah
that is better much better now you
cannot move the night as the root gangs
and if he place that I'm just winning
this thing okay so I had similar idea
but he gets to cover it so the thought
miss placings and height on v1 was
actually helping him so it was a bad bad
judgment I mean black is ok but it's it
shouldn't be it is not as good as it
could have been
f form yeah maybe I force the engine
move after that I felt I'm still much
better you know I did this it is the
keys here just just gone this point is
gone yeah this is more or less yeah win
for black if I'm not blundering stuff
okay can he can play it of course much
tougher and then queen before which was
just a guess mouse slip oops I'm sorry I
thought maybe Queen a4 was his idea yeah
well I'm relatively passive with my
pieces so it's not totally easy task but
like is clearly better it's it's a
protected pass on c5 very healthy porn
so it shouldn't be yeah it should be
should be a win with proper play okay
well thanks for watching